>> Tucker: YOU HAVE WAITED
ALL WEEK NOW IT'S TIME FOR
FINAL EXAM A BATTLE OF
RETURNING CHAMPIONS THIS
WEEK "SPECIAL REPORT" HOST
BRET BAIER WON YOU REMEMBER
LAST WEEK.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT ED HENRY
WON TWO WEEKS AGO BUT OUT
LAST WEEK.
TWO CHAMPIONS ENTER.
ONLY ONE WILL EMERGE THE
VICTOR.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> Tucker: HANDS ON BUZZERS,
I'M GOING TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST ONE BUZZES IN GETS
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU MUST WAIT UNTIL I ASK
THE QUESTION TO BUZZ.
IF YOU ANSWER A QUESTION
WRONG YOU LOSE ONE POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WIN.
READY?
>> LIVE TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: I LOVE.
THIS IT'S MY FAVORITE
SEGMENT.
QUESTION ONE, OLDEST SITTING
SENATOR IN AMERICA IS HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE
RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN HER
STATE REFUSES TO SUPPORT
HER.
WHO IS IT?
BRET BAIER?
>> DIANNE FEINSTEIN OF
CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: DIANNE FEINSTEIN
OF CALIFORNIA SAYS THE
ANCHOR OF "SPECIAL REPORT."
TO THE TAPE.
>> THIS IS NOT AN EASY TIME.
>> ARE THEY ALL LIKE THIS?
>> CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SLAMMING THE DOOR ON
DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
PARTY ACTIVIST DENYING THE
STATE SENIOR SENATOR
ENDORSEMENT IN HER BID FOR
RE-ELECTION.
>> Tucker: NEXT QUESTION IS
FAIR BALANCED AND FILL IN
THE BLANK.
JUST KIDDING.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU WERE NOT AFRAID TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION TWO,
MULTIPLE CHOICE, DID YOU
KNOW THAT YOU CAN CLONE YOUR
PETS AND IF YOU CAN BARBRA
STREISAND REVEALS THIS WEEK
SHE DID CLONED HER FAVORITE
DOG NAMED SAMANTHA.
WHAT IS THE FAVORITE RATE
FOR DOG CLONING, $50,000,
500,000 OR $1 MILLION?
>> ED HENRY?
>> 50,000.
>> Tucker: 50,000 SAID ED
THE WOULD BE DOG CLONER TO
THE TAPE.
>> SHE CLONED HER DOGS, TWO
OF HER DOGS MISVIOLET AND
MISS SCARLET ARE CLONES OF
THE LATE DOG SAMANTHA WHO
PASSED ON LAST YEAR AT ABOUT
$50,000 A POP.
>> I DIDN'T HEAR KILMEADE
BUT I HEARD LAURA INGRAHAM
TALK ABOUT IT.
>> DON'T EVEN HAVE A PET.
QUESTION THREE, OPRAH SAYS
2020 PRESIDENTIAL RUN COULD
BE POSSIBLE BUT SHE IS
WAITING FOR A CERTAIN
SOMEONE TO GIVE HER THE
EXPLICIT GO AHEAD.
[BUZZER]
>> WHO IS SHE WAITING TO
HEAR FROM?
>> GOD.
>> WAS THAT PREMATURE?
>> HOLD ON.
>> HERE'S THE QUESTION AND
ONLY OUR JUDGES BECAUSE I
PASS -- SO SLOWLY TO
DETERMINE.
THIS DID BOTH OF THEM CLICK
IN EARLY?
OH, ONLY HE HAD
OH, ENLY HE HAD
OH, EDLY HE HAD
OH, ED C HE HAD
OH, ED CLIE HAD
OH, ED CLICKHAD
OH, ED CLICKEDD
OH, ED CLICKED IN EARLY?
>> EARLY?
>> THIS IS LIKE THE NFL.
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY.
THIS IS DEFLATE GATE AT THIS
POINT.
AND I AM NOT GOING TO BE THE
NFL COMMISSIONER.
SO I'M GOING TO GO RIGHT TO
THE JUDGES WHO SAY WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A RECLICK.
OKAY?
SAME QUESTION?
HERE WE GO.
WE HAVEN'T FINISHED IT.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YES.
>> SHE IS WAITING FOR A
CERTAIN SOMEONE WHO GIVE HER
THE GO AHEAD.
WHO IS SHE WAITING TO HEAR
FROM?
ED HENRY.
>> COME ON.
>> THE ALMIGHTY GOD.
>> Tucker: THE ALMIGHTY GOD
SAYS ED HENRY.
TO THE TAPE.
>> BILLIONAIRES CALLING ME
UP SAYING I CAN GET YOU A
BILLION DOLLARS.
I CAN RUN YOUR CAMPAIGN.
AND I ACTUALLY WENT INTO
PRAYER ABOUT IT LIKE, GOD,
IF YOU THINK I'M SUPPOSED TO
RUN, YOU GOT IT TELL ME, AND
IT HAS TO BE SO CLEAR THAT
NOT EVEN I COULD MISS IT.
>> DON'T TELL JOY BEHAR.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU ARE
OPRAH, ONLY GOD CAN BE YOUR
CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
LIKE THERE IS NOBODY
ADEQUATE TO THAT.
>> THAT IS CONTROVERSIAL.
>> Tucker: TRUST ME IT WAS
AND SOME OF THE REPORTS ARE.
QUESTION FOUR, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT SECRETARY
BEN CARSON IS ACCUSED OF
SPENDING 30 GRAND ON
UNNECESSARY FURNITURE.
WHAT KIND OF FURNITURE WAS
IT?
BRET BAIER.
>> DINING SET.
>> WHY WE HAVE A DINING SET?
WE WILL FIND OUT IN THE
TAPE.
IS IT A DINING SET.
>> CARSON REPORTEDLY SPENT
31,000 TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON
NEW DINING SET FOR PRIVATE
DINING ROOM AT HUD IN D.C.
A HUD OFFICIAL IS QUOTED
ASSAYING THAT A CAREER STAFF
WAS BEHIND THE DECISION TO
BUY THE DINING SET NOT
SECRETARY CARSON.
>> Tucker: I'M A HUMANITIES
MAJOR I WILL CHECK THE MATH.
2-2.
THIS IS IT.
THE TIE BREAKER.
FINAL QUESTION.
MULTIPLE CHOICE.
THERE IS A MAN CURRENTLY
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS IN THE
STATE OF ARKANSAS.
HE SHARES A NAME WITH A ROCK
AND ROLL LEGEND IS HE NAMED
A ELVIS PRESLEY, B, BRUCE
SPRINGSTEEN OR C MICK
JAGGER?
>> ED HENRY?
>> ELVIS PRESLEY.
>> ELVIS PRESLEY IS THAT HIS
NAME?
>> ARKANSAS IS ABOUT TO GET
ALL SHOOK UP.
ELVIS D. PRESLEY.
THERE HE IS.
IS RUNNING FOR CONGRESS.
>> THIS IS LEGIT, PEOPLE.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THIS
POLITICIAN IS AN ELVIS
IMPERSONATOR.
I'M SURE I DIDN'T NEED TO
TELL YOU THAT.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS VERY
INTENSE.